what are those [ __ ] things are called
like Ynez or some [ __ ] they stand on the
side of a [ __ ] wall
what are they [ __ ] called why doesn't
that [ __ ] oh the ibex that's what
it's called hey why don't hey ibex says
why are you not falling ibex is stand on
the side of these [ __ ] walls and the
walls have nothing on it they could
literally stand on a [ __ ] flat wall
ibex is hey ibex
do you have a deal with Satan hey ibex
how do you suck and stick to the side of
a wall hey ibex use this stairs the [ __ ]
is an ibex doing dude
I bet that's the [ __ ] sexiest animal
dude I swear to God other female ibex
looking at male ibex and their [ __ ]
[ __ ] get so wet that they slip and
fall and their forelegs shoot out from
under them because they're like how does
he [ __ ] do it all ibex are David
Copperfield dude how the [ __ ] do i bec
stand on the side of the wall like that
they literally are just scrunched up
against the wall standing on nothing
hey dude how do you make march of the
[ __ ] Penguins when you should make
[ __ ] side of the wall ibex make that
[ __ ] documentary they're the ibex is
stuck to the side of the wall little le
nothing is under his feet how does it do
it magic or nothing I mean some
ancient people say that this side of the
IBEX is sticky therefore it cannot fall
but we all know that is not you because
I mean Google some of these [ __ ]
things will have him on the video
podcast for sure will show you it's ibex
I mean look at this [ __ ] thing
walking dude look at this thing walking
on the side of a wall the walls [ __ ]
90 degrees anyway every time my buddy
texts me I've got a buddy that texts me
about like girls that he's seeing and he
always does the slow play and he takes
so long like he'll be like yeah I don't
know I don't know if she's into me or
whatever and I always text him
I [ __ ] always text him a picture of
an ibex on the side of a wall because
like that's what he is he's just [ __ ]
standing in the middle of nowhere
shouldn't be and like figure it out
anytime you have a buddy that's like oh
no if she likes me or like hung out with
a girl seven times and hasn't like
[ __ ] at least gotten the like third
base whatever that is don't even know
what that is dick sucking or whatever
like you know secreto text him a picture
of an ibex stuck on the side of the wall
because that's what that [ __ ] is
you hang out with a girl seven eight
times didn't kiss her
hi backs hey dude you've hung out with a
girl seven times and all you did was
hold her hand and never got your dick
touched you backs that's what you are
Swach are yer backs no take your dick
out hey dude ibex stop taking her to a
movie have a date at home or highbacks
I mean to
come on man get it going dude I don't
know I don't know though you know I
don't know if she's into me
yeah Bex hang out with her twice hang
out with her three times and yeah
hanging out with her four times you get
encroaching on ibex territory [ __ ]
standing in the middle of your body I
want to see screenshots as your [ __ ]
baby duties I want to see screenshots of
you I don't know if she your buddy text
you I don't know if she's into me I
don't know if he's into me
whatever it is text a picture of an ibex
on the side of the wall and write that
right to your buddy he ibex